hello guys my name is Hoshino and
welcome back to episode 2 of Genesis so
basically you guys are unfamiliar with
the series we're taking a look at my old
blood and dare game is starting with
Genesis my very first one and we're
gonna see basically what it is made out
of and how we can fix it now I'm just
I'm just going to talk about how I wrote
the code and what things I did correctly
what things I did incorrectly and it
should just be a nice little series
where we take a look at how fun it is to
make games in 24 hours especially when
you're not very good which is the case
with with Genesis so this was my first
game really that I wrote and last
episode we kind of took a look at what
what it actually was so if you don't--if
not sure what this game is
it's called Genesis I made it in 2012 a
lot of under 24 here it is then you can
click on the screen right now to go back
to the first episode where I play the
game and I talk about it a lot and I
kind of give the directors commentary of
what that game was so definitely make
sure you watch that first episode but um
episode 2 now what we're gonna do today
really is just take a look at the code
right I'm gonna go through the code I'm
gonna familiarize myself with it because
I have not looked at it since but I've
been looked at it like for years right
since I wrote it basically and I'm just
gonna kind of talk about it and I'm
gonna point out some things that could
potentially become dedicated videos of
like let's fix this or let's rewrite
this so let's make this work so so yeah
it should be pretty fun and then from
then on like next episode I think we'll
actually start fixing or rewriting or
analyzing like one specific part and
we'll see how we go with that and if you
guys of course have any requests as to
what you want to see videos about in
terms of like to do with this code base
and everything then just leave a comment
below and I'll I'll see if I can make a
video on that the code is of course on
github there'll be a link in the
description of this video that will take
you to it it's like github.com fault
slash the turnover for slash genesis so
yeah anyway let's start so the main main
class is called game we have our main
method right here game starts off
Creedy I mean cause the constructor of
game which sets some stuff up
mainly you know setting the size here
three times it's fun
we got the screen here the screen class
I'm assuming is going to actually do the
rendering we created a new sprite sheet
and we don't assign this instance
anywhere either which is interesting
input equals new input Handler sure
that's static as well we set menu level
what does that do
okay so it plays the menu theme this is
actually going to be quite interesting
for me as well because this was one of
this this was like the first kind of if
you can call it that complete game that
I kind of wrote ever I think and so and
so it's gonna be pretty it's gonna be
pretty interesting for me to see well
that what that was like and what that
card what that code base was all about
but yeah basically hmm okay so we play
them anything we launched up the level
notice these things are static by the
way which is cool public static so if
the favorite two words of a novice Java
programmer putter but in all seriousness
here it's totally fine and then
apparently I guess we add 20 menu mobs
so I assume if we just upped that to 200
and launched this we will have a lot of
mobs yep many many mobs enough mops many
many mobs that's better
it's decent performance fun times
all right anyway that's not what we're
gonna do today we're gonna mess around
with stuff okay cool we start the game
well okay that's this time Matt let's go
I'm I always when I'm reading source
code I always like there's oh I just
realized how the screens cut off mmm
that's not good
wait hang on yeah half the screen is cut
off not love that you guys missed much
but I should probably fix that ah that's
that's better
so now the screens fixed you know I love
these kind of videos where I like it's
just like less you're still alive so
anyway we're back now you can see the
full screen which is going to be
important for later on but I as I was
saying about source code when I'm
reading through source code there's you
know there's kind of one of two ways you
can kind of go you can either kind of
just read it as the other page kind of
goes so to speak so you kind of just
read like for example this class just
chronologically is and you just go
through each method like this that's
okay but then there's also the other way
that you could kind of read this and
that is actually follow the function so
for example we call game and then that
call screen so it's basically I mean to
simplify my explanation it's kind of
like do I look at this depth first or
breadth first right do I look at this
just by following each kind of class and
how it runs or do I just kind of read
each each kind of component so I like to
usually combine the two kind of methods
so sometimes I'll see like for example
there's no point in me reading on the
start method does because it hasn't even
given gotten called yet but it also
might be useful to just skim over it so
feet of runway is of course to to deal
with that okay so this is the main game
loop as long as game is running you know
we have a little bit of a timer here of
course if the game is paused then we do
not update the game so that's
interesting so I guess like I guess
there has to be something else that one
pulls the game right how does Paul's
work so so see that's something else
that I probably wouldn't do nowadays
like in the main game loop if not paused
update like that's not I mean update
should still be running if the game is
paused because we probably want to do a
bunch of stuff I like input dot update
for example should probably get caught
and get called if the game is paused so
if we made it so that we have a like a P
key that just we press and then the PK
pauses the game or something like that
all we press escape and in pauses the
game that currently wouldn't work
because we you know we have we basically
stop all of our input handling while the
game is poor
the same so we stopped everything so I
guess the way that this game becomes
unpause and if we just do ctrl shift G I
think we can control shift F no formats
it all shift I have no idea
I think it's ctrl shift G I don't know
why that didn't work yeah there we go I
can't well that's useless that's private
when does this get set at all am I
missing something okay
I guess the I guess pause as always is
always false huh maybe I was something I
was going to add but then didn't okay I
guess okay cool whatever
moving on never mind that moving on so
the update this is kind of a big one as
update and render I guess which are the
two big functions from which everything
else stems after initialization so time
plus plus we have a little if time is
greater than six five are three six
three zero two zero for some reason not
sure why I wrote that doesn't really
need to be done I mean I guess I didn't
want the number going too high but what
is this like it's an int anyway I don't
know exactly what my theory was with
that maybe I thought that if it exceeded
the maximum size of an integer the game
would crash
I don't know again what I was thinking
but who knows input on update so okay so
this is an interesting way of handling
input that I don't do nowadays and that
was just basically creating a set of
fairly hard-coded kind of controls
so like up-down left-right using back
right and then of course running an
update method which query is the keys
array to figure out what's going on
right and then of course it's like
really solved for example with a Malta
false and then if the focus was lost we
you know we set all the case to falsify
that I don't really do that nowadays
because it's a little bit confusing what
I would do nowadays is probably have
well first of all I would probably make
this class static and call it like
keyboard or something and then and I
would probably separate I think keyboard
and mouse events this this didn't have a
mouse which is why I kind of combined
everything in input handler this game
just uses a keyboard and that's it
but I mean overall yeah I would probably
just
have like some kind of method here you
know like public and our public bullying
is key pressed right and then you can
take in a key event or just a key code I
guess and then you would return
you know keys key code or something and
then you could do it like some balance
checking if you really wanted to to make
sure that you don't crush the game but
anyway and then of course the usage of
that and then that would probably be
static right because there's a reason
for this not to be static as in we
really got one keyboard attached to the
computer and that's that's pretty much
the the intention right there's no way
to really have two keyboards attached to
a computer and use them without you know
without doing some actual raw input kind
of stuff like Java certainly woman will
not support that anyway that's your
gonna have to get into like some windows
API stuff for that so it's pretty much
in 99% of cases you're only gonna have
one keyboard to deal with all the
computers gonna recognize two keyboards
as one anyway
again unless you do like some crazy raw
input stuff that's what it's gonna be
like so there's no reason to not have a
static keyboard class in 99% cases so
that's why I would do it that way and
then you can you know make this static
as well obviously and then everything is
just gonna work pretty well and that
that means that you just don't need to
have any kind of instance of this
floating around I mean you will need to
supply Java with an instance which I do
here right in these two but it's more or
less like you don't need that instance
to do anything with it now so for
example if we look at the main menu I'm
sure there are controls here like input
down and you can see that we have to
kind of pass around as input handler
which is a bit annoying again like
something that you don't really need to
do because instead with this current
system instead of doing something like
you know if input down selected plus
plus you can just do input handle handle
a dot is key pressed what is it Kay
event
till VK down right you do something
simple like this and it's obvious what
you're doing here as well you don't need
to pass around the instance or anything
like that and that should work the same
way right you can see that I've got scan
navigate up and down right so that's one
thing I would probably do again if this
was like a more professional game than
sure like you might want to of course
abstract you know specifics of which key
does what so that you could you know
have like like a key mapping or
something like that which you could kind
of use so that of course the that like
your key commands essentially and you're
like controls would be configurable at
zero and serializable as like into an
external configuration file so not
something like that like it's totally um
it's totally there's a million million
different ways you can do this but one
way not to do it is the way that I kind
of did it which which I really dislike
this this kind of way of doing it
because it means that you essentially
hard-coded all your controls inside a
keyboard class which you then have to
pass instances of it around it's again
it's not very elegant I don't like it at
all so that's one thing
so we've already found something that I
don't like and now I'm sure this this
game will be full of that which is good
so I hope you guys enjoyed this kind of
style of stuff again I'm not gonna dwell
too much on that but I didn't show you
guys kind of an alternative as to how I
would do it I mean the other thing is I
am passing instances around but you'll
notice that this is public static right
so even with the old system inside like
main menu instead of passing an input
which of course I didn't have to do I'm
sure that like III started writing this
when this wasn't public static was
probably like private and well it's
definitely not static and then of course
I then like and at that point I credit
the main menu and then maybe later I
made it static or something because
obviously if I wanted to I could just
even if even if this wasn't a static
method this is heat press right even if
it wasn't a static method like for
example down isn't a static
isn't down is in a static field right
I can still just do main dot I'll game
dot input dot down right so I don't need
to have that and that's still fun so I
don't need to have that that instance
floating around there right so that's
one thing that is a little bit
interesting in a little bit weird and a
little bit let them dairy alright and a
lot of dairy is like a little term I use
but when something is like a lot I'm
dead in the sense and it's like it's
it's kind of rushed right and it's kind
of like this is kind of the code that
you write when you have 48 hours to make
a game and you don't really care about
details or coding practices you just
need to get the stuff down so it works
so you talk jamming all this crap coding
it's pretty normal right that's what
game jams are like unfortunately well
both unfortunately unfortunately because
sometimes you rip out some really killer
code I mean nowadays like the code that
I write of course will be at a much
higher standard than than what this was
but of course back then I had I think
less than a year of just programming
like at all it was less than a year I
think I'm it is game less than a year or
about a year actually since I actually
just like first started programming so
hey it is what it is okay so we weren't
an update we were kind of trolling
through update and seeing yeah that's
why we caught we found and put it up to
head and I was like that's interesting
okay so we update the menu if it's not
null that does nothing well I mean the
virtual functions will do stuff I assume
in fact they definitely will so like
main menu for example will this is the
update method so you can see the update
method of all these menus is pretty huge
I mean like the help menu and stuff I
think would just be yeah would just be
like well first of all so every menu
maintains a timer it's set to 18
whatever that means
I actually do know what that means so
one of the things that I did was last
time all rather when I wrote this game
well I didn't know how to make like a
key typed type situation right so I
didn't know how I could detect a single
key press and not repeat presses so
repeat press is the way when you
for example press a key and then you
hold it down and so you can see kind of
how like the way that Windows at least
deals with that is it sends one key like
one one command which is just depressed
right and you can see how there's a bit
of a delay like if you look at this I
was gonna say crosshair if you look at
the carat here right
when I press like the right key it
advances one spot immediately and then
there's a pause and then it advances
more right so essentially we have the
first press which is not a repeated
press and then we have you know the same
key being held down but the repeat count
goes up so essentially what I wanted to
achieve was by like the key type thing
is essentially have a way to only detect
a key press if it was the first press so
if the repeat count was zero and there's
no easy way to do that I believe in Java
I don't think you can easily detect if a
key is pressed or not so what I always
end up doing nowadays in Java is
basically creating some kind of system
where I keep track of which keys have
been pressed but not released yet so
basically as soon as the keys pressed it
goes into a list of press keys right and
you can only essentially retrieve like
if you ask the input handler if a key is
typed right you can only retrieve it on
the first iteration of it being pressed
right so if if it gets pressed right
then your games update logic flows it
will retrieve the fact that that key is
indeed typed that first time then the
input gets updated and because it's
still in the list it's no longer type 2
right like it's in its it's still being
held down so the next time you go
through everything
sorry microphone the next time you go
through everything it's going to
basically return false because that case
will be held down on the next loop so
that's what I end up doing nowadays in
Java because there's no simple like hey
I want to know if a case press but I
also want to know what the repeat count
is no you can't really do that I don't
think I haven't looked at into a dot
like deeply but of course like in window
like in like in Sparky for example when
you get a key event you can easily check
what the repeat count is and then of
course you can do something like if
repeat count equals zero then do this
right this isn't no way so because I
didn't back it back at like this time I
didn't think of that weird system where
I get again can like manage the list of
pressed case I didn't have any of that
you'll notice the input handler doesn't
have any of that and so what I ended up
doing was I ended up implementing this
kind of time and mechanic where when
when like when you press if you're on
the main menu press Enter or or space or
sorry this is like on help on the help
menu right then you basically start an
18 tick countdown which is about like a
third of a second or so it's about 300
milliseconds because this update will be
running at 60 times per second right 60
updates per second so it's about 300
milliseconds of just it this won't
function right so if I hold it if I hold
down the Enter key you'll see it will
actually return yeah I'm just holding it
down however if I just press it it's not
going to return immediately because
there is a 300 millisecond delay if I
got rid of that right so you can see
that this only works if timer is 0 right
so if I got rid of this whole time and
mechanic all for example start at the
timer at zero then you'll see that if I
press help it's gonna basically flash
and return back unless I'm really quick
like that see it's actually really hard
to get this to work
so that's why the timer exists in case
you guys are wondering but yeah it's a
bit comedy it's a bit of a hack
obviously but that's that's that was the
extent of my knowledge back then so I
just solved the problem by doing it this
way obviously that's not good because it
still doesn't work in the sense of like
if I want to hold this down it shouldn't
go back right it should wait for me to
release the key and then press ENTER
again or all spacebar right and that
would make me go back so it still
doesn't work really as intended but
whatever okay so that's that
and then of course we have a bunch of
text here which was this whole thing I'm
actually kind of surprised okay yeah so
this is how this worked right it was
essentially an array of strings right
one for each line these weird comments
here are for eclipses formatting because
I use control shift F along right which
you can see will just order form and
everything and and by obviously like if
you use control shift F and you don't
have these comments here then eclipse
will kind of make everything into one
line okay it actually won in this case
because my wrapping is set to let me
quickly change that so I can really show
you what I'm talking about because these
are so these are some in-depth videos so
if I set the line wrapping to like 100
and Leo know just like that you can see
that this is what it will do right and I
always have my line wrapping really high
usually cuz I don't want lines to get
wrapped usually I like I said I'll do it
manually nowadays but back then I was
like not so instead of creating these
monsters obviously if you put comments
here just empty comments Eclipse can't
move this line up here because if it did
this would now be a comment so that's
like a little hack to get eclipses
format formatter to not do bad things or
not do things that I don't wanted to do
okay so it was what I did right there
was essentially a ray of text an array
of strings one a strength rich line and
then I had a little for loop this was in
render notice and this wasn't even like
a Const or like a static little thing so
I guess this would be allocated every
frame or something I'm not sure if Java
would at all optimize that I mean if
this was like say plus plus I would have
probably just chucked static out the
front so that it only gets creative once
but again I'm not sure if whatever like
this does seem pretty dodgy and I'm
assuming that's the same as that it'd
have to be there's no way like that
stuff would have just been credit on the
stack I guess so
this is probably very inefficient
creating this allocating this array
every frame
but you know not it doesn't matter too
much I mean this game isn't particularly
difficult to to render or to like not
this game isn't you know a huge
performance kind of drag so to speak
so anyway over here in the for loop I go
through every line here and I render it
twice so I render it twice because the
first time you can see I render it as
black so the last parameter here is the
color so zero is black of course this is
why it it's a 24-bit color RGB RGB
integer color and we have zero for black
of course that for Wyatt and then of
course you can see the black one which
is rendered first is actually offset by
like two pixels right two pixels in in x
and y in x and y right so if we for
example didn't have that we will just
see the shadow and that's why you get
like see that's just the shadow and then
that's that and then the reason I did
that was because this text was a bit
hard to read like you can see that when
it gets over like the rocks for example
it's just it's just not as easy to read
quickly as you know if I had the shadow
here which just makes it a little bit
makes it pop a little bit more so that
was the reason for this for this like
shadow thing and of course this fall it
will just go through through these um
through these lines and actually like
the performance of God actually isn't
back right you can see this is about not
all right hang on help yeah so it's like
a hundred and thirty six FPS a lot of
that I imagine is because of Java's
rendering of the text I imagine that's
probably the bulk of it but I'm sure
that like frogs Anna and we can prove
that pretty easily if we just get rid of
like that you can see the FPS is now a
lot higher as I've doubled but also just
out of curiosity I do wonder if that
array so what was it like a hundred and
fifty
yeah 150 I'm gonna say 140 sure I just
move that up that make any difference
not really
all right so ah it is a bit faster than
that it's about the same right so I'm
sure the Java was doing something to be
like oh you make this same thing every
time I'm going to not make it slow for
you and of course the actual slowness
comes from java's text rendering which I
again have no idea how that works but it
would be software based I imagine and
yeah I mean rendering that many
rectangles of course fresh character is
not going to be particularly fast if
you're on a software renderer so yeah
okay cool yeah and then of course this
was the the shadow and then the main
text for four options which was just
back ok options was like a list of was
supposed to be like a list of options
you could press so main menu for example
you can see has a bunch of options play
helping about right and then essentially
I iterated through I'm actually quite
happy with myself that I didn't just
create like separate like I I mean I
used arrays and stuff like that's pretty
cool right like I didn't just like
create you know private string play
private string help private string about
or something I made like an array out of
this so that I could iterate over it
when I like rendered it for example over
here which is pretty cool right and of
course there's this stuff which is yeah
just like the main title and everything
and I also as I mentioned at the other
video also really like the menu for this
like it's like on top of the menu for
this is like on top of a live kind of
level I think that's really cool and
something that uh that I wish I would do
more often I'm probably going to do that
next time I really like menus that like
for example I think half-life 2's menu
for example was
I believe it was on some kind of like
live kind of level as in like you you
know I mean I guess it wasn't really
because it's like it moved and stuff but
there wasn't like a full kind of
playthrough going on or anything but
like instead of just having like a video
in the background or just to sell it
like background I think I really like
this idea of having an actual having the
game actually play right which means
that first of all it's gonna be all
random like it is here and also you see
the day/night cycle on and it's pretty
it's pretty cool so I'm kind of a little
bit proud of myself for for thinking of
that yeah I think that's a cool idea
not that it's like original or anything
but just something a little something
cool in this in this very cool
critically acclaimed game okay so what
else we have the about menu again that's
pretty basic you can see every one of
these has this timer mechanic I'm not
sure why I wouldn't just make its like
in menu for example I mean I could have
implemented the time of mechanic here
and then just called super update from
each of these things and then that would
have handled this line of code and this
line of code without me having to
implement it in each subclass so that
would have been nice I mean I still
would have had to have had to have had
this but at least it wouldn't be you
know this whole thing every time
yeah anyway whatever also I released all
the input every time I pressed anti
which was interesting I think that you
know the help menu does that as well
that's interesting just setting
everything to false on I know why I
think that's because no actually I'm not
sure why that might have had something
to do with not not processing in
particularly or something I'm not sure
okay
so I mean I've been talking a lot about
menus let's take a look at the actual
like what are we out like 20 minutes
it's gonna be a long video buckle up so
let's talk a little bit about should we
talk about graphics so the actual game
mechanics
and these videos men let me know what
you think about the pacing of these
videos because like I mean what I'm
doing right now is taking a while and
I'm not sure if you would prefer it as
hurry them up especially because these
are like the intro videos is in we're
not actually doing anything we're just
kind of looking at the code so I don't
know maybe like for next episode I might
accelerate it and I'm not sure what you
guys think of this so maybe just like me
rambling on about my my game I'm not
sure so leave a comment below and I'll
see if I can adjust but I'm kind of
enjoying this so I'm gonna keep doing it
this way I think for now
until I get some feedback so welcome
what we're going to do with this video
is we're going to probably cover
graphics and then next time we'll cover
game mechanics so like how like how the
how the game logic was implemented but
we'll talk about graphics now so level
and entity and although all those kind
of packages we'll talk about next time
because we've talked about like menus
and let's quickly talk about sound
because there's not much to this so this
was using the app look kind of sound the
Java provides it's extremely limited the
only advantage of it is it's built right
into Java so you don't have to get any
kind of external library and you also
don't have to load in Java effects which
again kind of counts as an external
library because you don't get it by
default so essentially I used the Java
applet kind of sound for that the only
the really the bad thing with it apart
from the fact that it's a very limited
API is that it only supports WAV files
like it might support some other files
but I'm pretty sure doesn't support
stuff like ugh Auggie's really the good
one the good format
I mean mp3 is kind of like mp3 typically
isn't used in games because of its
license but Auggie is pretty solid Oh
Gigi right so I use that nowadays but
back then of course I just used the wave
wave files because they were easy to
implement in the code right of course I
knew that they were terrible but but
they were kind of easy to implement the
reason they're terrible is because of
the size of them right I mean they're
not terrible that good
they're terrible for games because you
don't really need that like ridiculously
high quality and it's not even that it's
ridiculously high quality is just
there's no compression right so you end
up with pretty huge files and I'm just
trying to find where on earth my
workspace is at and we're back
so Rin resources you'll see the sound is
not like if we were to look at the size
here you can see that like we know older
all the sound effects are fine
but the I mean the main theme is 58 Meg
right and then the menu theme is 24 Meg
which is crazy I mean this does go for
like five minutes which is why it's five
minutes 11 seconds which is the entire
duration game and then this goes for two
minutes so there they are quite long but
you can see they're the absolute bulk of
this like I mean this sound folders 81
megabytes which is totally unacceptable
it's way too blodge which is a problem
because of course it took me a while to
upload and with australia's internet and
it took me and it just takes a while to
download from slow servers that are
being like for example i was i think i
was self hosting this back in 2012 from
like one of my servers which back then
of course was a just a shared like $5.00
per month type deal so it was
downloading it like i mean the it would
the speeded the download would drop to 0
bytes per second frequently because so
many people were trying to download it
at once and then of course when it was
really to unload him Darin and stuff
people from the download and it was just
that was bad right it feels bad for
distribution because first of all people
had to wait like an hour to download it
and no one wanted to do that so thought
slice people played it but also also
it's just kids you know bandwidth wise
for the server I mean I would have had
unlimited bandwidth with that terrible
shared hosting thing but still it was
it's just not it's not a great way to
stay in shape so to speak so I would
have of course minimized this to have
like an OGG file which probably would
have reduced the total size from 80
megabytes to like 2 or something which
would have been totally acceptable and
totally fine okay maybe not true maybe
like five to ten but still would have
been a lot smaller so that's that's the
sound situation and there
nothing much to it here you loaded just
by doing a platoon you audio clip I
believe you have to have this in the jar
file though which is why you can see I'm
using sound uh class type cat raceless
right so I'm getting it relative to the
jar file essentially which is why all
this has a /leading fall slash in front
of it because it is essentially just
getting it from the it's getting it in
it's getting it from inside the archive
which is the Java archive which is the
jar file so yes whereas that's another
thing I should note by the way I believe
I do that for everything if you look at
text is that a class nor sprite sheet no
well I mean yes also you can see that
also gets the resource from here but I
believe mmm game would have done that
right yeah so you can see I just get
that from slash sprites and I get levels
from slash levels so yes ever
essentially I was packing everything
into the one into the you know I was
backing everything into the job or
archive and the reason I was doing that
the big reason I was doing that was
because of course I was releasing this
as an applet as well and back in the day
back in my day right back in 2012 none
of that was that long ago but back then
applets worked right they don't now
obviously because of security issues and
because Java is terrible and because
everything just and I mean applets are
terrible I will be honest but back then
at least they they was possible to get
them working and it's pretty easy
actually to get them thrown inside a web
browser which was perfect but nowadays
it's just not gonna happen so no one
should be making applets nowadays if
you're making a game in Java you should
just be making it downloadable I mean
that's really the only way if you want
to use a if you want to work on a web
then you're gonna have to write some
kind of wrappers doesn't something like
that and it's going to have to be
compiled in something else like for
example Sparky and other game engines
such as unity and unity and unreal as
well will use em script and to basically
compile into JavaScript right I mean to
compile their core engine which is
written in C++ for both unity and unreal
into they work they will compile that
into JavaScript and then they can of
course just load in the
set files and as if as if it was on
running on desktop just the JavaScript
sliding it now so that's the way they
get their stuff working with WebGL and
of course unity did have that Web Player
thing which it is retiring because that
was kind of like an applet and that's of
course chrome is like blocking on stuff
so that's all being disallowed so
everything is moving towards WebGL which
requires kind of em scripting to come to
convert your C++ code into JavaScript
very very magical how it actually does
that but it works and I have made Sparky
work with that as well which is been
about a year since so I had a working
version of Sparky within script ins but
I would like to kind of get that running
again anyway getting a bit sidetracked
here but that's that's the deal so
because it was written as an applet I
had to make sure that everything was
packaged inside the jar file because
applets are not particularly forgiving
even back then with loading external
files nowadays since most of the games I
make off a desktop wor like you know
essentially not for web right I would
I definitely load them as separate files
I don't I never packaged anything not
that I use Java too much nowadays anyway
but even if I did like ya I would be
having them as standalone folders and
there wouldn't be in a em they wouldn't
be in they wouldn't they wouldn't be
packaged and so inside the Java file all
right graphics let's quickly look at
this churn or color dot Java now I would
have called this class color but I
didn't want to because of the Java color
thing so that's the one thing that i
guess i just restarted called turner
color so there wouldn't be any confusion
and I said that I wouldn't have to use
the package namespaces directly every
time I wanted to use shona color or Java
color or something so I decided to just
call this channel color this is a static
class it looks like yep it's got two
methods change brightness and tint so
tint I believe what does that actually
do tint okay so you provide a color and
it essentially will add it will it will
add or subtract from each channel of
this color
you give it in the RGB right so if you
say like the color is white and then you
say minus ten plus ten plus ten or
something then it will subtract 10 from
the red color and add 10 to both the
green and blue Channel right so I guess
it's kind of a tint effect yes but you
do provide this stuff and then I guess
yeah
I mean it it's a tint of that that's
pretty simple that's the main code for
that oh and these are doubles why these
doubles why are these doubles I mean
they given cost to end anyway that is
peculiar so that it tint is used in
because the intensity is a double okay
interesting I guess I guess I just
didn't want to cast it here so I moved
it the cost into tint but yeah so the
tinting is used by the light rendering
and the reason I do that is because and
he gets tinted to RGB so you can that's
kind of cool actually
so what I ended up doing for the
lighting is I essentially ended up like
when I render the light I can give it us
a color and this is actually very mild
but you can see that the color we end up
with is kind of a blue kind of it
actually doesn't have much red in it
surprisingly one thing we can do by the
way cuz I do want to see what this looks
like but I also don't want to wait
around a lot is I believe we can
actually change the speed now which time
increases so day and night brightness so
the brightness changes right so it's
just plus plus well this is some weird
code so we have a return statement here
and then just a brightness plus plus
just any way how that is interesting and
yeah this definitely is not fantastic
card I would have done something like
just if-elsif and then not returned
because that means that this time thing
is a bit weird but anyway there's the
t'others there's a speed at the time
being called
so essentially if we can we'll have to
set this to a multiple of 50 essentially
or something that is something that yeah
I'm not really a multiple of fifty a
something that is divisible the Pitti
divides into essentially so like five or
ten would work but if I made five times
faster and that's probably still not
fast enough let's bring it ten times
faster so unfortunately we can't make it
like twenty times faster because if we
do that then yeah there we go
so you can see how fast that's going now
so if I and it will pause it won't fall
so I got a hurry so I can like for
example tint this to like a hundred and
five or something and I I think it
should essentially make it red but I
don't think it did hmmm that intensity
is tiny I guess but also I'm not sure
why I didn't taint it very well I don't
know man I don't know how this works I'm
just guessing okay that that's not red
but you can see kind of how that works I
mean I'm sure that I'm not clamping
something which is why this is happening
but yeah you can see kind of how the
color tinting works right
yeah it's totally not red anyway that's
that that's Turner color and then the
other one is brightness so change
brightness so basically you provided a
color
so these functions are very very simple
right you essentially provide a color
and you provide an amount that you want
to modify right same with both of these
and then essentially it will make sure
well it'll clamp the amount to a certain
range in this case zero to negative 150
right so basically when you change the
brightness or something in this case you
can't make it brighter it has to be this
has to be a negative number it has to be
between negative 150 and zero and of
course it will literally just add the
amount to each color Channel and then of
course it will just make sure that the
color channels are all clamped correctly
again I should have just written like a
clamp
because I'm clamping a lot here we've
had all of these clamping whatever
you're dealing with solar colors you're
always clamping anyway
and then of course I do that so here's
you guys aren't familiar this is really
simple so extract a channel from this
main color do some stuff apply the
amount right make sure you know clamp
the clamp a channel to its balance which
is 0 to 255 and then reconstruct the
color back into a single integer so
that's the old the channel separately
right because a channel takes of one
byte and that's pretty much it so this
change brightness would be used for
making everything darker which is what
happens at nighttime so you can see it
happens in like well random Alban stuff
and this is all the lighting stuff that
actually doesn't work
lighting is definitely one thing I'm
going to fix in this game because the
mob there are lighting bugs with the mob
sin with the player but also you know
foreigner tile as well we can see that
the color changes based on the level
brightness and the level brightness of
course changes when this time gets
ticked which is like not very often it's
going to its I mean this was this was
just time plus plus so it essentially
takes once per second ish right it's a
bit faster because its mod 15 or month
60 if it was mod 60 be exactly once per
second so it's a little bit faster than
once per second but essentially once per
second we in this case would you know
change the brightness yeah I'm not sure
why I needed to have two variables for
day/night I could just had a bullying
day and then of course is if day is
false then night is true like I've kind
of got going on over here so I'm not
sure why I made two billions for this
stuff I guess like because the only
advantage of this is it provides a state
in which either it is both night and day
or it is neither night or day which
course can't be a thing so a little bit
weird but anyway it is what it is it's
been like 40 minutes holy crap I've got
stuff to do with my life
sorry I have to wrap this up we're going
to talk about the graphics and the
rendering next episode and then if we
have time which I bet we won't because I
seem to be stretching out these videos
just
massively um we will I'm so tired
we will do that thing that I will do
that thing that I said we would do
yeah the game that the game logic and
all that stuff alright so anyway hope
you enjoyed this video if you did please
hit the like button leave your feedback
as to what you think of I'm going to
fast if I'm going to if I'm going too
fast if I'm going too slow or something
or you're not enjoying this or you think
this is terrible we think it's great or
you want more of this just leave a
comment below and I'll sort I'll sort
you guys out and that's about it so I'll
see you guys next time goodbye warm